♪ Yeah, okay, it's Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Sippin' in some Vee ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Puttin' out all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with GaryVee ♪
♪ Might go make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Yo, good morning everybody.
Welcome to the first day of May.
May 1 in the building.
Super excited to be here,
hope everybody is doing
well, families are well,
I'm ready to get into the show.
Dustin our one and twos,
thank you so much Dus
for everything you've been doing.
Big, big, big shout out to my man Mozzy.
Put out a banger of an album last night.
I've been enjoying that, I shared some
on my Instagram story and Twitter.
If you don't know M-O-Z-Z-Y,
you're making a huge mistake.
Anyway, let's get into the show.
- Gary.
- Gary!
- It's a pleasure to be with you today.
- Thanks Asher, thanks Joey.
- How you doin'?
- Quite well, you?
- Really well.
- We're doing well.
- Better now that we're with you.
- Good.
- So we know you're a busy guy
and we only have a few minutes
so we're just going to hop right into it,
if that's all good with you.
So Joey and I, he's 17, I'm 19.
We started our first
media startup last year
and we launched our first podcast.
It's called The Debate
Without Debate Podcast.
And our sole mission of that podcast
is to end polarization
through conversation,
just like we're having right now.
And so based off of that, our
main question to you today is
Gary, do you view yourself
as a polarizing figure
and if so, what are some of the benefits
that you've received from that?
- I don't.
I do understand that some people do.
I am comfortable speaking
my mind about things
I genuinely believe in.
I'm not trying to, you know...
I think anybody can be viewed polarizing
just on the fact that we live in a
politicized environment where one opinion
that you actually believe, in a nice way,
may not jive with somebody else's.
I tend to be more polarizing in the
businesses that I'm in.
I challenge status quo a lot,
which people view as polarizing.
I view myself as practical.
You know, I happen to communicate
in a Jersey style that I think...
I think cursing may seem polarizing,
high energy and conviction
may seem polarizing,
not accepting the norms of society may...
Actually, I'm clearly very polarizing.
(laugh)
Look, I think "polarizing,"
much like other words are...
You know, "ego" and "confidence",
people think they're the same,
I think they're completely different.
Polarizing and passionately practical,
I think are very similar
but wildly different
and I think I'm passionately practical.
- See, as an up-and-coming media star,
we find it kind of difficult
to cut through the noise sometimes.
It seems like most
traditional forms of media
or social media for that matter
kind of emphasizes this
polarizing, extreme nature.
Gary, do you think there's even a market
for non-polarizing content, and if so,
what does that business model look like
on an applicable scale?
- There's an ungodly amount of it.
I mean, I haven't taken the time
to really audit the things
that you would decide
with your subjective
opinions aren't polarizing,
but for every extreme Fox or extreme CNN,
or even me, I get that I'm high energy,
I think entertainment works
and I think information works.
And I think entertainment
has taken over the news
in a lot of ways and that's
led to a lot of muckery.
But I'm sure there's
scientific journals that have
great B-to-B businesses
that do quite well.
There's an ungodly amount of
business people I respect
that are not over-the-top.
Mary Meeker puts out one of the
best reports each year on
start-up and VC culture.
She's not polarizing
by people's standards.
Is Sheryl Sandberg's "Lean
In" a polarizing book?
For some, yes, for others, no.
I think people look at
production and think
that's part of the polarization.
What I mean by that is,
there's a lot of people
articulating incredibly thoughtful work
on YouTube, podcasts, Medium, the press,
and there's just an ungodly
amount of good content
that comes across very calm.
Like, do you consider most of
NPR's content polarizing?
If you're a Republican hardcore, you may
'cause you don't like
the things that are said.
But I think in the way it's delivered,
it's quite calm, you know.
And does extremely well,
I'm sure that if you went
through the top 200 podcasts
right now on iTunes,
and clicked them all, you would agree
that half of them are bombastic.
Howard Stern, Barstool,
and I think you'd find
half of them are just
kind of quite mundane.
And then the question becomes,
are we judging polarization
on style or substance?
You know, I think for me, one
of the things that works is
I think I have a style.
Which by the way, hampers
me in a lot of environments.
There's an enormous amount of people
who don't like me without
even having a sense of my substance,
they just don't like Jersey talk.
And that's okay, I actually respect that,
I'm empathetic to that.
But I think there's always
a market for good stuff,
and yes, does sizzle sell steaks?
Yup, you know what else sells steaks?
Delicious fucking steaks
that don't have sizzle.
- Love it, love it.
Gary, if we could have one last question.
Given that you've
started your own podcast,
GaryVee Audio Experience,
we love that stuff.
What would you do if you had
zero pre-existing social capital,
you were Beta Gary, and you
wanted to just launch a podcast?
We have a lot of listeners
who are interested in starting again,
I know they--
- I did it on February 21st, 2006.
- It was called Wine Library
TV and nine people watched.
- So what can you do to grow?
- Aside from just producing content.
- So there's two things.
The biggest thing that will help you grow
is something that allows
you to grow sustainable,
which is putting out quality content
and quality content doesn't
mean the production quality,
it means other people on the other side
find you funny, smart,
interesting, entertaining,
period, end of story.
There's always ways to be smart
about your post-production
and your distribution.
It's called making the content contextual
to the 15 websites that I talk about
fuckin' every second of my life.
LinkedIn and Tik--
- Yes, sir.
- The reason I bring
up LinkedIn and TikTok
is because there's organic reach.
But that doesn't mean that
if you don't have dollars
that Facebook and
Instagram are scary good.
The ability to do what I
did on Twitter still exists.
Go into Twitter, search the
words of your subject matter
and literally reply to
every human that's on there.
Are you willing to do
it for 14 hours a day
like I did for four years
with limited results?
Most people don't have that conviction.
Most people don't love
what they do enough.
I don't want people to do things
for 14 hours and burn out either.
Put in three hours, but most
people put in zero hours.
Asher and Joey, most people
are putting in zero hours
of going into Twitter,
searching the conversation
and replying to 40 people.
Zero.
- Very true.
- People have audacity and expect
that people are just gonna follow them.
It's audacious.
- Very true.
Gary, pleasure, really a pleasure.
- Thank you, guys.
- We look forward to
seeing you again soon.
- Can't wait, hope so, take care guys.
Audacity.
Let's keep going.
Tanner, what's good?
- Hey Gary, how's it going?
- It's going really well, and you?
- Good, good.
- Good.
- So a little bit of background.
My dad started a karate school
when I was four years old,
and I grew up learning the
martial arts, started competing,
and 2014 I won a world championship.
So my whole life I've been doing this
and I haven't really figured out
how to monetize my skill.
- What comes through
your mind on selling it?
Like how do you think about selling it?
- I would love to be on social media
and just produce content that way.
- And make money through ads on YouTube,
or brand deals or self-subscriptions
or sell merchandise or start a school?
- I mean, the first thing
that comes to my mind
is sponsorships, ads.
I have started a school.
I'm actually working at a
grocery store right now,
like 40 hours in the morning.
- Thank you for being
in those front lines.
Tanner, I mean, you could start
making YouTube videos
and start getting ads
from the YouTube videos tomorrow.
You know when somebody comes
to you and they've never
done martial arts, and they're
never really worked out
and they're like "Hey, I
wanna be a black belt."
- Mm-hmm (laughs).
- Right?
And even the fact that
you just laughed that way,
what goes through your mind immediately
because you know your craft so well
is "Okay, buddy," and right?
You know people say to you like,
they mean it too, they roll up and
"Dude, I wanna be a black belt."
And you're like awesome, are you ready
for 15 years, right?
- (laughs) yep.
- That's kind of what
you're saying right now
about monetizing through
being an influencer.
Like, it's fuckin' work.
- You just start now, and--
- Now, you may have
natural talents, yeah exactly.
You know this, everybody wants a shortcut
in their martial arts, like "Yo, bro,
"can't I just watch a bunch of videos?"
Right?
- Yeah.
So it's just all about the drive--
- That made sense to you, right?
- Yeah, 100%.
- It's a lot of work, bro.
I've been making content
every single day hard
since February 2009.
And that was after I fuckin'
worked 15 hours a day
being an entrepreneur
in a store for 11 years.
And that was after
really being in business
for 8 years doing baseball cards
and making 3, 4000, $2000 a weekend
selling cards as a kid
and having that skill.
And that was after seven years
of being seven to 14 doing things like
washing cars, shoveling driveways,
singing Christmas carols for $1.
Starting a mini flea
market, a mini golf course
in my friend Robbie Turnick's backyard.
You know, hustling.
This is fuckin' 37 years
of work in the making.
37 years going hard, not kind of.
You know?
Think about how hard you work
at the grocery store 40 hours,
that was three days of my workweek.
Like, hard, hard, hard.
- I feel you.
On top of that, I get up
at three in the morning
to work at the grocery store
and then once I'm done after that,
I'm working on my karate school.
- That's hard, I'm impressed.
Start putting videos on YouTube for sure.
I think TikTok is the fuckin'
golden goose right now.
I would make two TikToks a day
about your karate stuff, it
will work, you'll be shocked.
- Sounds good.
- Awesome, brother.
Talk to you.
- Awesome, thank you Gary.
- Take care.
Hi Liza.
- Hi Gary.
- How are you?
- Can you hear me?
- I can.
- Okay, first off a huge thank you
for you and your incredible team
for motivating people
across the entire world.
My question targets
primarily young adults.
So for the people that chose
a different path in life,
not the typical nine to five lifestyle,
but more into passion and
pursuing their passion.
So I started my business
about six months ago
and ever since the feedback
from my parents is negative
and they're not supportive towards me.
And it's not easy to
really strive for more,
so what would you suggest
to balance such a lifestyle?
- Yeah, so what kind of business is it?
- A ballet business,
I'm a ballet instructor
in the Chicagoland area.
- I love it.
And your parents think it's too high risk,
are your parents immigrants,
what's the punchline?
- Yes, they're immigrants from Russia
and they never were business people.
They were on the typical nine to five,
and they don't understand the
being your own boss mentality.
- They think you're in danger,
like you're going to fail and
it's going to set you back?
- Yes, it's more of their
thinking of the safety
and it's not as much safety
as what they have in their careers.
- Yup, so are they really getting at you,
like how combative is the conversation?
Is it disappointment or is it more
even like putting you down?
- It's putting me down
and basically telling me
that I won't be able to do it,
or I have to do something
different on what they did.
But I don't want that,
I want to do something
with passion and to pursue something
to make a difference in other
people's lives, mostly children.
- Are you struggling
with it or not really?
- With my business, I'm
actually not struggling--
- No I apologize, with the feedback.
- With the feedback, yes, only because
I'm still living under
the same roof as them,
so coming home from--
- Are you able to not
live under the same roof?
- That is what I'm
working on, to move out.
- Do you have friends that
you could slum it with?
Meaning, do you have friends
that might be willing to,
like the sooner the better.
You know that, right,
because it's gonna be--
listen, I have a lot of
empathy for your parents.
Obviously I come from
that part of the world
as you know, like a lot of the people
that came from that regime don't
have entrepreneurial spirit
because most people don't
have entrepreneurial spirit.
And second, that system
was based on socialism
with the aspiration for communism,
which is the state will take care of you.
And it goes to "be comfortable."
Listen, you're gonna win
this game, I'll tell you why.
The fact that you're
even here on this call
means that you're aware of me,
you're aware of an
alternative conversation,
and more importantly, if I
didn't exist or anybody else,
it's intuitively in you.
This is the only way you see it.
I think one of the moves that you can do
is not be combative with your parents
but actually be empathetic.
You know, when they're coming at you,
it's hard to not either a) be upset
or b) go back at them.
I actually think the answer might be c),
which is being compassionate to them.
Being like, "Mom and
dad, I thank you so much
"for what you've done for me,
"I understand that you're only saying this
"'cause you're scared 'cause
this is how you see the world.
"But you have to understand
that even if I fail
"and then get a job like you want me to,
"that's what I have to do,
"otherwise I will resent you
and be unhappy my whole life.
"So I love you for trying to push me,
"scare me, challenge me into doing
"what you want me to do for my life.
"But that's only gonna lead to me
"not loving being around you,
"it's only gonna push us further apart,
"maybe this fails and I do get the job
"that you want me to,
"however, I have to do this and
"I'm doing this for two reasons.
"For myself, and for you guys because
"if I take the bullshit job
that you want me to take,
"and at 37 I resent you that I didn't
"follow my dream about ballet,
"that's gonna lead to a bad
relationship between us."
Listen, you know I'm telling you this
with somebody that understands Soviet DNA.
I actually think that
the ultimate strength,
the ultimate push against
that hard pressure
is compassion and empathy.
- Yeah, that's what I'm working on,
to not live under the same roof as them.
So as soon as that happens, I believe
that everything will come into peace
between me and them.
- I don't think so.
Because it's still gonna be in the air.
Just 'cause you're not there,
you may not have to hear it as much,
but it's gonna lead to peace.
They still genuinely fear you
doing something like this.
Have you told them that you're
empathetic and compassionate to them,
or have you gone quiet, or
have you gone combative,
like what's been your reaction to them?
- Mostly just quiet, I don't really
communicate with them at all
because it's negative energy.
- I get it.
- Because it's not gonna help me,
it's just gonna bring me down and
positivity is just not how they view it.
- And do they understand that
you're distancing yourself?
- Yeah.
- And what is that making them do?
Who's more upset about it, mom or dad?
- I think both, to be honest.
- Do you have siblings?
- Yes, I have a younger brother
so he's kind of the...
- Mediator?
- Yeah, the show of the family.
- I understand, how old are you
and how old is your brother?
- So I'm gonna be 24
this summer, and he's 12.
- Love it.
Look, I think you're on your path,
I'm really proud of you.
Stay strong on this, here's why.
You're doing a huge
favor for your parents,
not just yourself.
If you actually succumbed
and lived your life
based on what they wanted,
you would end up resenting them
and having a bad relationship.
So instead, you're gonna
have some friction now
but you're gonna have a much
better relationship later.
- Right, okay.
And one more thing I wanted to ask you
about everything going on
right now in the world,
a lot of people are feeling
stuck due to COVID-19,
so what would you suggest to,
when everything goes back to normal,
for the people that are scared they won't
be able to adjust fast
enough to their routines
and their lifestyle before COVID-19?
- I would remind them
that they didn't think
they could adjust to
COVID-19 and here we are
three weeks later and they're adjusted.
- Yeah, okay.
- Right?
- Right.
- I mean, you know.
So this must be a
nightmare for you, right?
Because getting out of
the house is the best
and now you're like, "Fuck."
- 100%, exactly, it's not good.
- Are you taking advantage
of modern technology
and things like this and just consuming
and building community and just--
- Yeah, that's exactly--
- Listen, Liza,
let me give you a very
good piece of advice.
Feel a lot of compassion for your parents.
I know it's crazy but you know this,
and I know this, where they grew up
and how they grew up
is some fucked-up shit.
Like, fucked -Up shit.
If you actually are empathetic to them,
I really think it will
help you be happier too,
and I mean that.
And don't do it just because I'm saying,
like really take a step back and be like,
look, this was their reality.
They grew up in outer space compared to
where we grew up.
- Yeah.
- Really.
You know, they did.
How old are your parents?
- In their early 50s.
- They grew up in a fuckin' outer space.
They just see the world differently,
they didn't have this opportunity.
And they might have some resentment
that they didn't, and try
to impose that on you.
But that's not because they're mean,
it's because that's how life works.
You really need to think about this,
it's gonna help you a
lot, I'm telling you.
Running away from it is gonna be fine
and you'll have short-term happiness,
but I'm telling you there's
a way to combat this
that's sustainable so there
can be a lot more happiness.
I mean it.
And I'm sure your--
- You would just suggest
compassion towards this problem?
- I would.
You know deep down, you know
how your parents love you,
this is what they think is right.
They don't want you to be miserable,
they just genuinely believe it's right.
They do.
They think they're helping
you, they love you,
they're based on fear,
which makes a lot of sense
where they grew up.
You're not, you're fearless.
- Right, thank you.
- You're welcome, but I
would also even tell you
that maybe even guilt would help you.
You feeling guilty that you were blessed
with fearlessness and
growing up in America,
and they were given fear or
maybe they were conditioned.
Maybe your mom was exactly
you but she just had
the luck of the draw of being
born in the Soviet Union
and you had the luck of the draw
being grown up in America.
You know, if you go with that,
all of a sudden it makes their feedback
feel a little bit different.
- Okay, thank you.
I also started my
Instagram and TikTok videos
all very recently so if you can go ahead
and just check out my page and Instagram,
I'd really appreciate it.
- I will, and I will
ask everybody to do that
and I do think TikTok
could really work for you.
But I'm not letting you off the hook
on this robotic answer
on this last little part.
Listen to me, it's
going to help you a lot.
Just like really lean
into being empathetic
to where they're coming from.
- Yeah, I will do it.
- You know how they got there.
This is a classic, classic immigrant story
for so many of us.
Russians, Asians, Indians, it's so real.
I already can tell, and even just the way
you were wrapping up the call,
you're gonna be fine because
you're too strong-willed.
And you're just gonna go fuckin' do it
and you're gonna show
'em and you're gonna win.
I believe that, I actually believe that.
But when you win, how you
win is gonna be important,
not just the fact that you won.
And you control that.
You can approach this very differently.
You can be the bigger person even though
you're the younger person.
You could.
- Yeah.
Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
- I'll definitely work
on this and really--
- Do you think you can?
Or do you think you're just appeasing me
and we're wrapping up here?
- I think I can, and I think it's true
because it's gonna help me and them,
but I just wanna also hear your opinion
because you have this similar story
coming from eastern Europe
and immigrating here.
But my parents were never business people.
- And that's okay, right?
- Yeah, of course.
- You know, it's okay.
And my parents worked me like a dog.
You know, there's all sorts of versions,
there's all sorts of things
but you have the control.
You have it.
You have the rest of your
life in front of you.
You were given the blessings
of their risk that they took.
You can be the bigger person,
they don't have to be.
Everybody thinks their
parents have to do it right,
as if that's the rule.
You can do it right, which then may
turn them to doing it right.
Which is also gonna help you.
- Okay, thank you.
- All right, talk to you soon.
- When you are in
Chicago next I would like
to have the chance to meet you
if that's possible, and also your team.
They did an incredible job of
setting all this up, thank you.
- Awesome, talk to Dustin,
thank you, take care.
- Thank you so much, bye-bye.
- You're welcome, bye-bye.
- Thank you.
- All right, interesting shit.
Hope that helped a lot of people,
that's a super, duper, duper
common theme for so many people,
immigrants and non-immigrants.
Parents' expectations versus your reality.
You gotta really, really figure it out.
And yes, when the person said "Man, is it
"that bad to be from the Soviet Union?"
Yes, Martin.
People don't understand
what that regime was.
People were getting murdered, people were
going to jail for 20 years.
Anti-Semitism was insanity.
People were sad.
Go look at every picture of every person
in the Soviet Union from 1945 to 1985.
You'll just see no smiles.
Yes, it was that bad.
Let's keep it going.
- Oh, shit, Gary!
- What's good?
- What's up, bro?
- What's good, fam?
- Bro, it's the first time I've seen you.
I was supposed to see you in El Paso
but I didn't get a chance
to go over there, so.
- It's a pleasure.
- Yeah, I have a question,
so I'm a barber, I'm a licensed barber.
I wanna provide value to the audiences
as I create the content, right?
So I don't know if I
should just teach people
how to cut hair, or just
show me cutting hair
at the same time talking about my--
kind of have my personality in the content
within it, you know what I mean?
- Of course, your personality
is the only differentiator.
Everybody that's good at cutting hair
is good at cutting hair.
The only difference you
have is your personality.
Like, talk about Batman.
- Batman, Batman.
- Well, you're wearing a Batman shirt.
- Yeah, I have Lego Batman
on the PSP, but yeah.
- But yes, the answer
is yes to everything.
Yes other people's, yes
yours, yes personality,
yes technicality, yes yes yes.
Anytime you think, should I post this?
Put a little Gary on your shoulder,
you know that fuckin' angel?
You know, right here, I'm
gonna make a little toy
and put it on everyone's shoulder.
Actually, I'm gonna make a T-shirt.
Team, I wanna make a T-shirt where there's
a little picture of me
and it just says yes.
Dustin, you got that?
Little shirt, plain shirt,
little fuckin' face of me and just yes.
And I just want people
to fuckin' wear that
and I think that that's the game.
Yes, Adrian, the answer's fuckin' yes.
- Yes, okay well another thing.
So I have a lot of insecurities.
Just growing up my mom
was really strict with me,
just wouldn't let me go out the house,
no friends, no social contacts,
she was too scared for me to go outside
so she kept me inside with video games.
I was really creative at the time
'cause I didn't have any
people to interact with,
so that built insecurities
- That's good.
- Within me, so basically what I did was
I tried to be the
smartest person in school.
And that didn't help, so
I became valedictorian
in high school, recently
graduated high school.
Coronavirus messed up
it up, still graduating,
I ain't worried about it.
You know, it moves on, life goes on.
If you were to tell me "You're wrong,"
I would just take it so offensive.
But then I stopped doing that,
I stopped doing that
'cause if there's no reason
you know, maybe I thought--
- And it makes sense.
If your mom was so authoritative,
that means that you got
built up in that environment
and so that makes sense that you value
other people's opinions because
your mom's dictatorship
became your framework,
that makes a lot of sense to me.
That's okay, that's okay.
I could tell you right now, just on video,
I think you have a great
natural human personality.
I find you very comfortable on video
and interacting with me,
I think you'll do great with people.
- Okay.
- You feel comfortable around people?
- Yeah, sometimes I do
get a little bit sensitive
like really fast, you have no
idea how fast I get sensitive.
- Because you're insecure.
- Yeah, that's why but it's like--
- Well, good news.
- I'm trying to fix it
but it's so hard.
- Lemme help, no, we're gonna fix it,
we're gonna start right now.
I got a secret for you, you ready?
- There's a secret, yeah.
- Put your ear to the
camera, I'll tell you.
Brother, everybody else sucks too.
- I know they do.
- So that's it bro, don't fuckin' like,
if they say you're not good-looking,
then say they're not smart.
If they say that you're not smart,
then you can say they're not funny.
If they say that you're poor,
you can say they're spoiled.
Like, everybody else sucks, bro.
- Okay, all right.
- But do you understand?
- Yeah, I understand.
- Like, the second somebody hurts you,
just convert that energy and
hurt them back in your head.
You don't even have to
be mean, I'm not mean.
- But you speak a lot about
kindness and I wanna be kind,
like there's people that have--
- You heard what I said?
I love to train--
- I like--
Really nice to them--
- That's good, I hear you, no problem.
It's a little choppy,
but let's keep it talking
'cause this is a powerful conversation.
- I'm nice to them,
they could talk so much,
like talk shit about me,
but at the end of the day
I'm like you know what, maybe something's
going on with them, maybe it's not me,
maybe it's their family,
maybe they lost a game,
maybe they're just mad for no reason,
maybe... I don't know,
there's too many maybes
out there for me to just
assume something about them,
so I always--
- I fuckin' love you.
- You know what I mean?
- Facts.
Do I know what you mean?
It's my religion.
- I was gonna get back to you--
- Brother, being kind to
somebody that's mean to you
is the fuckin' ultimate strength.
People think that you're soft,
people are like "Gary, you're soft,
"you let people take advantage of you."
I'm like, no I don't.
No I don't, I don't care
what they're saying.
I don't care if they stole money from me.
That means they stole
money from me one time.
You steal money from me,
it's the biggest mistake
of your life because I'm worth
a lot more than what you took.
So what's the problem?
- The problem is that
I don't know whether,
how can I say it, whether
I'm a businessperson,
'cause I grew up with business people,
like my grandpa had a business,
my uncle has a business,
my mom has a business,
I know the business world, like how they
create their businesses, all right?
But at the same time I
grew up being a student.
So let me give you an example,
so I watched your content for about a year
and then there's a point where
I watched one of your videos
and it said that "Stop being a student,
"stop just learning, start doing,"
and that's when it got to me,
'cause I was just learning
and learning and learning
like I was in school.
You know what I mean?
Instead of actually putting in the work.
So it took me a year to realize that.
- Good, you're a fuckin' child.
Most people don't realize
that in their entire life.
- I'm 18 actually, so yeah.
- I know what you are,
you're a fuckin' child.
You just told me you
graduated high school.
I know you're 18, you're
a fuckin' child, bro.
- Yeah, I have a lot of
time ahead of me, don't I?
- A lot?
You have 100 years ahead of you.
You're part of the generation
that's gonna live to 120.
- That's what I've been tellin' them,
they don't believe me,
I tell them I'm living to 100,
but they don't listen to me.
- Fuck them, who?
Your mom, your uncle, your friends,
who gives a fuck?
- You're right, who gives a fuck.
- Who gives a fuck?
- No, it's just really
hard not to give a fuck.
I don't know why--
- It's very easy
to understand why, you have a mom
that dictated a very strict
infrastructure on you
so you valued her opinion
which translates to you
valuing everyone's opinion.
- Yeah, that's exactly--
- That's your answer.
I'll save you time.
- Yes, that's it, thank you.
- Well, guess what?
Now you're young enough, you're listening
to the right things,
we're hanging out here,
hopefully this is a stepping stone.
And you need 100,000 other stepping stones
and then you'll retrain your brain
and it's like cutting hair,
you get a new haircut.
If you shaved your head, you
would have a different haircut.
You're now gonna think
about it differently,
you're changing your mind, I can see it.
You've already got it in you.
- Yeah, I feel like it's just natural
'cause as soon as I started watching you,
everything you said, I was like,
you're the guy that I
need to be listening to
because you're telling me things
that I don't like but at the same time
it's the stuff you need to be telling me.
You know what I mean?
- You can feel like it's right for you,
it's uncomfortable because
I'm poking at holes
but at the same token, you
know that there's truth there
and you can tell that it's
coming from a good place,
and that's what made it attractive to you?
- Yes, 'cause you're so kind,
your personality itself,
you're a nice person, but
you just look like a dick
when you talk in your Instagrams
but you seem super nice.
You're the nicest person I've
ever met in my life, man.
Like, your personality,
the way you talk to me man,
you're being honest to
me, you're being truthful
but at the same time you're not
showing any hate towards
me, you know what I mean?
- Hate?
I love you.
- Yeah, there's no hate,
you have no hate, man,
you feel nothing but positivity.
- No, I have conviction.
To your point, I like the game.
Listen, a lot of people come to me
and they're like "Gary, duh duh duh,"
and I'm like, this person for 29 years
has been given advice this one way.
And that's why they're not happy.
So when I "look like a
dick", I'm just trying
to cut some shit out, I'm going in deep.
I'm making myself vulnerable.
I'm letting people think I'm a dick,
I'm taking on the pain
of judgment from others
to help that single person,
'cause a million people watch that video
and you're like, "That
guy's a dick" on Instagram,
and I'm like fuck.
I'm taking those fucking
hits to help that one person.
My reputation to half the
world is going in a bad place,
I have to be patient for 25
years to be fully understood,
I'm taking that loss for that one person.
- Yes, I understand.
I showed my mom your videos and
'cause she doesn't believe
anything that I tell her
about being nice, you gotta think
long-term, not short-term.
And I show her your videos because she's
not gonna listen to me, she
thinks I'm just a child.
But I don't care,
- And?
- That's the way she grew up--
- And what did she say?
- She said you're on the right path.
She doesn't know half the
stuff that I'm talking about
but I understand that maybe her life
wasn't as educated as mine's, perhaps.
- It's circumstantial.
So wait, you show her the
videos and her reaction is what?
- She's like, "All right,
I'ma start doing it,
"can you help me?"
'Cause she doesn't understand--
- That's awesome, that's good.
She's transactional.
That makes sense to me, my father is too.
When you come from zero,
it's hard to go up here.
She didn't have the luxury
that you and I have.
- 'Cause I was lucky enough,
I was really lucky enough
to live in the middle
class and go to school,
but then I don't feel
like school is for me
because I feel like I'm--
- Good.
- The system is not
right for me, you know?
- So, don't.
- Like you said in one of your videos,
you're trying to break the system,
that's what you're trying to do.
- I am.
- I fully respect that, yeah.
- So, great.
Bro, if you were a stock,
I would invest in you.
I hear everything that I like.
You're a nice kid with
clarity, this is great.
Do you think you have the work ethic?
- The work ethic, yes.
- Good.
- I actually worked
construction since I was 12.
- Yes.
- My stepdad put me into it.
- Bro, you're a fuckin' Amazon,
I wanna invest in you, you're gonna win.
Bro, do me one favor.
Remember this forever, kindness
is the ultimate strength.
- Kindness... all right.
See, I'm sensitive right now.
- It's the ultimate strength.
- I don't know why I'm
such a sensitive person.
- I'm sensitive too bro,
I cry during Lion King.
I cry in every movie,
I'm sensitive as fuck.
Sensitivity is great, it's why you have
so much emotional intelligence.
- When I got married,
people were just talking
so much shit to me like, "Why are you
"getting married, why are you doing that?"
Like, I'm making decisions based on
what I think is right,
how are you gonna tell me?
It's just something like--
- Bro.
- Little things that people judge you
that they don't even understand
where you're going with it.
- Bro, you have to understand,
you look at them and be like,
"Hector, Sally, Rick, Tom, Salvador,
"I love you for saying this, thank you,
"you go have fun until you're 35,
"for me, I wanted to be married at 18.
"I fell in love.
"I understand what
you're saying, thank you,
"thank you Sal for saying that.
"Now you go worry about your life."
- Yeah, okay.
- Like, say thank you.
- Comma, go live your fuckin' life.
Sal, you don't like getting married at 18,
you go fuckin' hook up with
chicks until you're 40.
Mazel tov, go have fun.
Good, I'm happy for you.
What makes me happy is this.
Brother, do not put
other people's opinions
on a pedestal when they're
not living your life.
Tell them to live their fuckin' life.
- Okay, but that's being mean.
- And by the way,
listen to me--
No, it's not being mean.
- But it's like--
- You said thank you.
- Then they take it personal,
you know what I mean?
They take it personal.
- You said thank you.
- Yeah, thank you.
- You didn't say "Fuck you, Sal,
"Get the fuck out of my business,
"I don't respect the way you bang chicks,
"fuck you, you're a piece of shit."
You said, "Thank you Sal, comma,
"I appreciate it, comma,
"this was what was right
for me, I fell in love
"and I was okay with it.
"You know our grandparents all
"got married these ages, comma.
"Comma, I'm so excited
that you're gonna have
"lots of fun in college and date
"and go to the big city, good!"
- It's crazy how that's
exactly what they tell me.
- I know what they tell you,
that's why I'm regurgitating it
so you know what I'm talking about.
I know what the fuck I'm talkin' about.
- Yes, you do, you actually do.
You've been doing it for about a year,
I've been texting you on Instagram
saying you're always right, man.
You're always right.
- Thank you, brother.
Listen, I'm not always
right, but I'm always
coming from a very clear point of view
that's right for me.
I'm not necessarily always
right for everybody else,
but there are things
that everybody can take
that can help them.
I don't want anybody to
be me or do it like me,
I want everybody to do
it that works for them
but there are things like
kindness and empathy,
brother, sensitivity is the
biggest strength I have.
I cried every day until I was 15.
I cried when the Jets lost, I cried
when somebody's feelings got hurt,
I cried when people picked on other kids,
and it didn't make me feel nice
'cause I could feel that kid.
That later became why I
was right about TikTok,
why I predicted Tea with
GaryVee 10 years ago.
My sensitivity is my fuckin' superpower.
- All right, okay.
- It's a gift.
Compassion and sympathy is a gift.
Bro, I cried when fuckin' the Lion King's
lion dad cartoon died,
cried in the theater
with my fuckin' friends,
hot chicks from high school
sitting right there, cried, cried.
- Dang.
Yeah, okay.
I'm tryin' to understand everything.
That helps me a lot
that I'm actually going
the right way, I'm
thinking the right things.
- I promise you this,
the next time one of your
clown friends makes fun
of you or has an opinion,
tell them, "I appreciate it Sal, Hector,
"but Gary Vee thinks I'm awesome
"and you're a fuckin' asshole."
So there you go.
- Man as long as you think I'm cool,
that's all that matters to me.
- Bro, I think way better than cool,
I think you're a fucking great kid,
I'm sticking on this call
because I wanna be with you.
I think you're lovely and kind and capable
and have all the fuckin' elements
of having a tremendously impactful life.
- So just thank you, thank
you so much, actually.
- You're welcome, brother.
Talk to you soon.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Okay, bye-bye.
- Bye.
- Dustin, you know what's interesting
about this show is like...
It's funny to go through the process
of communicating your truth.
- What do you mean?
- Meaning like, I've always
known who the fuck I was.
And throwing out "I'm gonna buy the Jets"
is like an easy, peacocking,
"I'm not fuckin' around here"
move, but it's not deep.
It's like "Yeah, I'm
gonna buy a sports team."
It's actually douche-y.
Some of the shit that's happening here,
I've never articulated the
judgment I get at scale
for trying to help
somebody that comes across
that audacious or rude.
I'm a human, that doesn't feel good
when you know you're up to something good
and people dismiss you as bad.
Especially when you're sensitive and nice.
- Yeah, I'm surprised, I
don't know how you handle it.
I can't do that.
- It's kind of like
your gift is your curse.
It becomes your domain.
I can't fuckin' spin a
bunch of handlebars around
in one shot, I watch your videos,
I'm like, I'd skin my knee,
be unconscious, and be sad.
That's scary to me, I'm not doing
those flips shit, fuckin' spin
and fuckin' jump off a
fuckin' curb, what the fuck?
You know, everyone's themselves,
but like people are so surface-level,
they're not paying attention
to what I'm doing out here.
And that's why Tea with
GaryVee's been so powerful,
I definitely think that I've pulled
another layer of the onion away
and I think people are seeing
it, I really believe that.
- Yeah, people are definitely seeing it.
- They don't even fuckin'
know Dustin, they do not know.
Nobody watching around understands,
I'm not fuckin' around here,
I'm winning the whole fuckin'
thing, the whole thing.
Nobody else, me.
I'm the guy.
I know it.
- I know it too.
- Let's keep it goin'.
(exhales sharply)
Hey, Heather.
Hi, Gary.
- How are you?
- Hi, how are you?
- Good.
So I'm a makeup artist from
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
And I guess I'll just give
you a little backstory
of kind of who I am, I guess.
I'm a first generation college student.
So my mom's from Mexico and college
was basically forced on me.
Like, I'm going to
college, it's happening.
- You're checking the box, I got it.
- They'll support me, I have to go.
Yeah, I'm going for it.
So I decided to go into
pharmaceutical research,
so chemistry, biology, blah blah blah.
I hated it, I just absolutely hated it.
I didn't like watching bacteria grow,
I didn't like going to labs,
I didn't like writing the reports,
it wasn't for me.
So of course trying to drop out of college
wasn't a thing either,
'cause my mom's not gonna
let me drop out of college.
So I just stopped going to classes.
I got myself in so much debt,
and it was all private loans because
my family didn't know
where to get it from.
We didn't have money
for me to go to college,
so I'm still dealing with that.
But I finally was like, "I'm
not going to classes anymore."
I started playing
makeup, practicing makeup
when I was just sitting in my dorm
and people started showing interest like,
"Hey, can you do my makeup,
can you do my wedding,
"can you do this, can you do that?"
And I was like, "Oh, I
don't have any experience,
"I don't know what I'm doing
other than my own makeup."
So I finally told my mom "Sorry mom,
"I'm gonna go to school for makeup."
So I came back to the
cities and I am now a--
- What did she say?
- Oh, you know it didn't go over well.
She's like "Well, how are you gonna
"make a career out of that,
"is it going to make you enough money?
"You're already so much money in,
"why don't you just
finish, blah, blah, blah?"
I'm like "Mom, I barely made it through
"a first year of biology let alone--"
I didn't even make it
to a chemistry course
'cause I was like, forget it, I hate it.
I kind of just told her "I'm so sorry
"but I'm just going to do this
and we'll see how it goes."
- I'm proud of you.
- She's in the cosmetology world too,
so she already knows how much you have to
work your ass off in this industry.
So she's like, "Are you sure?"
- You have to work your
ass off in every industry.
- Yeah, so I mean, I've
watched her for many years--
- If you wanna be successful, I got it,
keep going, awesome.
So I love everything about this story,
the debt pisses me off, but keep going.
- Oh, I know, it pisses
me off too (laughs).
So I went to school for multimedia makeup.
So I basically can turn
somebody really cute
or I can turn 'em into a zombie
in two seconds, you know?
- Really cool.
- Yeah, it's really fun.
I run into the issue that
when I went to school,
'cause Minnesota doesn't, you don't need
a license to freelance,
I found myself in the bridal industry.
So I went with an agency for a while
when I first got out of school in 2016.
And I worked for an
agency for a couple years
and I realized, I'm only making about 50%
of the 100% work that I'm doing.
So I'm like, goodbye--
- Fuck this.
- I can do this on myself.
I'm like, you're basically
running a credit card,
I know how to do that, too.
So I went over and I started
my own bridal business
so I do weddings as
the seasons come along.
The issue that I run into is that
since Minnesota doesn't
require you to have a license
through Board of Cosmetology,
I can't work in a salon because they're
ran through Board of Cosmetology.
I'm neither esthetician
or cosmetology-licensed.
So I lose that aspect
of having a clientele
being able to come somewhere regularly.
- So go to them, or...
- Oh yeah, I absolutely do that.
You build a clientele and repetition--
- Real quick, real quick.
I know where you're going, so real quick.
Just like some people
think, like your mom,
that college was the only
path to making money,
and you were like "Go fuck
yourselves, I can do this."
I understand that salons
are a feeder for clientele
and finding new clientele.
So is fuckin' TikTok and Instagram.
There's nothing you're gonna say right now
of the values of the license
that isn't arbitraged around
by you making creative on
TikTok and Instagram, nothing.
- Absolutely, I've been doing--
- Let's stick here for a second.
If you're saying absolutely to that,
I wanna put a nail in that coffin.
Like, you know the answer.
- Well they're trying to pass the law
'cause they're trying to regulate us, so--
- Fuck the law.
- Yeah, Board of Cosmetology is
coming for bridals super
hard because they know--
- I know what they're doing.
- It's a pain.
- They're trying to force you to--
- I mean, I'm not worried about it.
- 'Cause you can go somewhere else.
You can move.
Fuck Minnesota.
- The cold is really a pain in the ass.
- Yeah, fuck Minnesota, other
than the Minnesota Rocker,
the Esports team I own in Minnesota.
Fuck Minnesota and fuckin' move
if they pass some law that fucks you.
Don't worry about what other things
and other people are doing.
- Right, absolutely.
- Nobody's going to the salon right now,
it's fuckin' COVID life.
- That was gonna be
part of my question here
is because I rely so heavily on clientele,
that's where my work comes from,
I have to be person-to-person interaction.
And so my biggest focus right now
is I have my Instagram account,
I don't know if it's linked or not, but--
- It is.
- It is my professional page,
so I obviously post my
clients, I post my weddings,
I do special effects,
just dabble in everything
just because I like playing makeup.
But I found that on social media
because makeup is being...
the Youtuber makeup,
it's everywhere you turn.
You're seeing a new eye again
or a new this, that, that.
- I got it.
- And working makeup artists,
I feel like they got lost in social media
over the Youtubers and
them doing their own makeup
versus us going out and doing makeup.
- No, they don't get lost.
They don't get lost.
- I see a lot of companies
focus around the Youtubers
a lot more and give a
lot more recognition--
- 'Cause they have much bigger audiences.
But their personalities--
- And they build very quickly.
- You could, too.
- And how do I show my
personality behind the camera
instead of saying "I
wanna apply my blush here
'cause that's where blush goes,
not understanding, you know.
You probably know how to do
your makeup at this point
by watching all the videos
that come up through the feed.
So I had started another Instagram
because I don't wanna be
the working makeup artist
with 1000 selfies, like
"Oh I do people's makeup
"but it's only pictures of me."
Because those ones get more interaction,
they're like "Oh you're really, like...
"I love your makeup,
love it, blah blah blah."
I'm like okay, then why
don't you go say it like
commenting on and letting me know
what you think of client makeup,
because that's what I actually like to do.
So I end up deleting a lot of my selfies.
- Why?
- I like clients being
able to come to my page
and see my work versus seeing...
- But you can mix it.
- Yeah.
I had a good mix, I was just seeing
more of my face, my face.
I'm like, this is not
what I want people to see
when they come to my page.
- So do a different mix.
Like what was your mix before,
how many client photos--
- With COVID, how do I go about that
because they just extended us
another almost three weeks out.
And I can't do clients, so...
'Cause I started a YouTube,
I gave in, I did a
YouTube doing my makeup,
just showing how to do makeup.
- Heather, you know what...
You go by Heather or Heather Marie?
- Heather.
I mean it's Heather Marie but you know--
- Heather, you know how
your mom put college
on a pedestal and it fucked you up?
- Mm-hmm.
- You're putting influencer
dynamics on a pedestal
of an ideology of how you see the world
and it's fucking you up.
- Yeah, it is.
- I know.
- And I know that, and it's the worst part
because I'm just like, God--
- Good news, I know it too.
I'm trying to help you here.
- I just don't want to be that Youtuber
and I know my value, I know my worth
of who I am as an artist,
I hear it, I've never had--
- Heather, Heather, Heather.
I know you do.
Guess what, Heather.
I want to make garage sale videos
to help people learn how to make
from zero to $100 but most
of my business friends
thinks it makes me look bad
and people won't take my
real business advice serious.
But I don't give a fuck what they think.
You're repeating your mom's
mistake on your own self.
Your mom put school on
such a ideological platform
because of the grind that she went through
and didn't want that for
her wonderful daughter.
But she made you go into debt
on something that brought you no value,
and it was the wrong move.
You have judged these
non-technically-sound
makeup artists who are "fluff",
who've amassed millions
of followers on YouTube,
and in your judgment of them,
you've held yourself back from the growth.
I promise you, me rummaging
through people's trash
doesn't underestimate the fact that I have
accomplished everything
that I've accomplished.
You taking a selfie that you look good in
doesn't undermine your actual work.
Your ideology's fucking you up.
- Even though I don't like it?
Even though I don't like
the selfie situation?
- Well, let's talk about that.
'Cause it's a great question, thank you,
you just helped a lot of people.
Even though you don't like it.
No, I want you to be happy, and happy
over business success, period,
end of story, no debate.
The question becomes
"Why don't you like it?"
To me, that's the most important part
of this conversation, Heather.
No, I want you to be happy,
and I don't give a fuck
if you make less money,
have less opportunities,
but you're asking me, we're talking,
and it's under the guise, I assume, of you
having more success, AKA happiness.
It gets scary when everything shuts down
and you wanna diversify your
income, I'm sure, right?
But here's the real question: why?
Do you feel like being
valued for being pretty
undermines your intellect?
Are you actually insecure of how you look?
Do you not wanna be associated with people
that you disrespect how
they handle their lives?
There's a lot of real fucking questions,
Heather, under there.
It's not as simple as "I don't want to."
I wanna know why.
- I just wanna push my work out more.
- So do more, so post three times a day
with two works and one you.
And by the way, you talking
about which coffee you like,
you humanizing yourself will lead to
so much more opportunity
which will lead to
people more seeing your work.
I'm trickin' fuckers
into being better people
by disguising myself as a businessperson.
The fuck do you think's going on here?
Your work will get more look.
- I know I get in my head so much,
well, I don't know exactly
where I wanna end up,
but I know my train of
okay, this is where...
'Cause I know the steps, I
know what needs to happen.
It's just I wanna get there, I don't know,
I know I get in my head.
- I know how you
wanna get there.
No, no.
You wanna get there based
on an ideology you created
instead of actually getting there.
You value the ideology more
than actually getting there.
I'm telling you you do.
You know what's even scarier about that?
You're valuing other people's opinions.
- Yeah, that's my issue too.
That, I know.
That's the most frustrating part
is when you know your flaws,
you know what's your issues
and it's just like you can't get past that
because what you're doing
is making you happy.
And it's like well, those
other things are still there,
they're still lingering,
they're still in that section.
- Of course.
- And it's like ah, get away,
I know what I'm supposed to be doing.
Pay attention, people.
My opinions of other people,
I already told my mom,
my mom out of all people like,
"All right bye, see you," you know?
- More importantly, I think there's an
underlying judgment you have
towards those other people
because you were blessed with talent
so you're judging other people which then
makes you susceptible to being judged.
Do you know why I don't
struggle with judgment?
It's 'cause I'm not judging anybody else.
And then you're spending time
looking at their channels and their posts,
and fucking judging
the people for liking--
- I do support, I'm like
"Yeah, I like that video."
And it's completely the
creative fantasy, crazy makeup.
It's a complete art, I love
everything that they do,
it's more the side of when I have a client
sit down in my chair like
"Oh, are you a Youtuber too?"
or "Oh, how do you do your makeup?"
or "Do you do the crazy
this?" I'm like ah, no.
- Heather, Heather.
I have successfully operated and built
two major businesses through
blood, sweat, and tears
and a fuckload of smarts.
I have been one of the wiser,
more strategic investors,
I have systematically been correct
about so many consumer
trends over the last 20 years
at the highest levels in the world.
And almost everybody rolls up at me
and they're like, two friends
roll up, they're like,
"Gary Vee!" And they other
friend's like, "Who's this?"
He's like, "Oh, that's that
"motivational speaker on Instagram."
I've put nothin' but fuckin'
Ws on the board for 20 years
and I'm the motivational
person on Instagram.
"He's that funny guy that
sells trash on TikTok."
That's literally what people say.
Who gives a fuck?
If you know who you are,
what the fuck does it matter?
You're way, way, way off on this.
You're way off on this in a real good way
'cause you're super close.
I'm pumped, you're way off, and close.
That's why this is fun for me.
You're way off, but you're close.
You're close, you just
need to drop this one.
I'm a motivational speaker
to 90% of the people,
it makes me throw up in my
mouth and wanna go to sleep.
I'm not a motivational speaker,
I'm fuckin' an executor
at the highest levels
who happens to be
motivated and optimistic.
You're not a fuckin' Youtuber,
you're a fuckin' big-time
talented makeup artist
who happens to make
fuckin' YouTube videos.
Enough.
Who gives a fuck what
Sarah from Minneapolis
thinks when she sits
in your fuckin' chair?
- Right, fuck Sarah.
I have another question.
You had done an interview with Sam Parr
and he had asked you
about other businesses
that you were interested
in or upcoming businesses,
or e-comms or whatever it was.
But you had said men's makeup.
You were interested in men's makeup
and you didn't get to
touch back on it at all
and when I heard it, I was like
"Oh my god, he's finally gonna
answer a makeup question!"
I was super pumped and obviously
you guys ran out of time, but...
- So I'm out of time now
for this episode as well,
but I'm not gonna do it to you again.
Let me just look at my schedule... fuck.
Okay, so I believe that
men's makeup, straight men,
not the incredible communities
that are alternative.
Straight men are going
to actually wear makeup
in the world and I think
it's going to be at scale
somewhere in the next
10 to 15 to 20 years.
I believe it fully.
100% I believe that will be true.
- I mean, I don't see why not.
You got a pimple, cover
it up, you don't like it.
- No no, I'm not talking
about some of the places
that men have dabbled into, like coverup.
I'm talkin' eyeshadow,
I'm talkin' like me having
a fuckin' lightning bolt
on my cheek every day.
I'm talkin' real shit,
I'm talking lipstick.
- (mumbles) type of thing.
- Yeah, I think if you look
carefully in TikTok culture,
the 14, 15, 16, 13, 12-year-old girls,
the guys that they're attracted to
are clearly in that direction.
The e-boys are in that direction.
Long hair, highlights, you
know, nail polish, lips,
like it's already happened.
I don't predict, I don't
guess, it's already happened.
Now it just needs to play out.
Social acceptance.
Online dating, when I told all my friends
it was gonna happen,
I love that Calvin Night believes this,
screenshoot this real
quick for me, Dustin.
Because that's gonna go in the archives
'cause Calvin Night's gonna
fuckin' take a huge loss.
Just like all my friends that said
online dating wouldn't happen,
just like all my friends
that said nobody was gonna
go on Facebook that
aren't already in college,
just like all my friends that said I was
wrong about TikTok and Musical.ly.
People don't get it,
I'm never gonna be wrong
because I don't guess.
I've just watched so much carefully,
I listen so much more.
I interrupt people, I get that.
But nobody on fucking earth
is listening more than me.
I'm telling you that right the fuck now.
I'm in the fuckin' game
when it comes to listening,
of course there's other
people that are listening
as much as me, but I'm
in the fuckin' game.
And it's already fuckin' happened.
- You're just ahead of
people, you already know
and I do the same thing, I'm a terrible...
I try to catch myself like "Heather,
"let them finish their thought,"
even though you already have
the answer and their solution
and this and that.
It's like, I say to my clients
when they sit down in
my chair they're like,
"Oh, I have this," I'm
like, "I can see girlfriend,
"like I got you, we got it."
- By the way, I'm sorry to interrupt.
- You already have the answer.
- I get it, I get it.
Eric Thompson said "Strong John Wayne
"and Clint Eastwood is gone,"
it's actually not gone.
I think they both
coexist, I actually think
old school men, like hard
pail, like tough guys.
I think that's emerging, too.
There's a lot of things happening.
It's just such an interesting time.
Heather, listen to me.
You're so fucking close but
you're so fuckin' wrong.
And it's really exciting,
I think this could be, you're super close.
- My brother was the one
that turned me on to you
a couple years ago and
I told him, I was like,
"Oh my god, I might talk to
Gary Vee in a couple days."
He's like, "All right,
well be ready to sit there
"and know he's not gonna bullshit you."
I was like, "I don't wanna bullshit."
I was like, "I want him
to sit there and just,
"this is what you're doing wrong,"
because I know I'm so
close and I'm just like,
I need someone to like...
I mean, not validation or anything--
- You're right there.
You know, we're humans, we're humans.
Affirmation is a real powerful thing.
You are so fucking close.
You just need to know
that your mom was wrong
about her ideology about college,
and you're wrong on your
judgment of Youtubers
and social media people.
- Against YouTube, okay.
Sorry, I'm trying not to take your time
but because I started another page
because I was in the
idea of keep my selfies
on one page and my work on another,
do I just keep it all on
the handle that I have?
Okay.
- Yup.
All you.
- I don't have any viewers
on the YouTube that I did,
so let me kick it back to the other one.
I just didn't know how
I should separate it
and if I should or not.
- Easy, stop shitting on other people
and your dream of how
you should be looked upon
as a professional, and
start fuckin' living
your honest, full life on it.
Awesome, I gotta go.
- Okay, thank you so much.
- Bye, you're welcome, Heather.
- Bye.
- All right, fuck, man.
I don't know, Dus, this
might have been a--
Jesus, this was good.
That was some real fuckin' fire.
There was some real stuff.
The Russian girl,
Heather, you know, right?
Like there was some real stuff.
The 18-year-old, the post-edit
team needs to get to work,
it was a fuckin' fire episode.
WineText.com, if you don't sign up for it,
I'm gonna kick you out
of having the ability
to watch this stream, I'm done with you.
We're not friends, it's
over, I'm finished, see ya.
That's real, and the All-In challenge,
my auction is running up on
Saturday, tomorrow, it's over.
So if you've not bought
your raffle tickets,
please please do that now,
here is what I'm offering
on the All-In Challenge, love you.
I am giving away the
ultimate GaryVee experience,
how should that go, 'kay.
Over the last week or
so, I've been jammin'
with my friend Michael
Rubin and helping out
on this All-In Challenge that
I am accepting right now.
But allinchallenge.com, please go there.
We are challenging some
of the greatest artists,
entertainers, athletes in the world
to provide a ridiculous
all-time experience
or one of their most iconic
items in their collection
to help raise money to
help feed the hungry
during this ridiculous time
and so now I have to put up my auction.
So my auction, the ultimate
GaryVee experience,
here we go, I'm gonna go
off the top of the head.
And you can go on allinchallenge.com
to go bid on this,
I am giving away, okay, you get to,
in the course of a year, you will go
garage sailing with me
and film "Trash Talk."
Also you can get a workout
with me and Mike Vacanti,
so I know a lot of you pay attention
to that part of my world.
Also we're gonna go to Wine Library
and do a $25,000 shopping spree.
That's right, I'm gonna
pay my dad (laughs).
Well, I'm gonna donate, we're
gonna pay my dad $25,000
so $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library.
I will walk through the
whole store with you,
tell you the war stories,
and you'll buy a bunch
of wine, beer, liquor,
whatever you want, food.
We are going to go to
a Jets game together.
You're gonna tailgate with me.
I never do this, when I
give away Jets tickets
I never let the person sit with me.
So you will sit with me
during the Jets game.
I won't talk to you during the
game, I'm completely focused,
but you'll get that.
So the ultimate Jets experience, tailgate,
full game with me as well.
Also I'm going to give you one week play
at VaynerMedia, so this is for you
and a plus one, by the way.
So the two tickets,
we'll do some plus ones,
we'll do some just me and
you, depending on what it is.
One full week at VaynerMedia
getting consulting
and business advice
from Team GaryVee and me
for the entire week,
hanging out in the pit
where the show's done.
You're gonna be a guest on my podcast,
we're gonna do a wine dinner for you
and seven of your friends
at Hunt & Fish Club
in New York City.
And I'm gonna fly you, all paid, plus one
to three of my keynotes, and
we'll work on those details.
The ultimate GaryVee experience.
I hope you bid on it, I
hope you get involved.
I hope we raise a lot of money
to help people that need it.
Also what's so fun about
the All-In Challenge
is you get to challenge
people to be in it.
I am gonna challenge all
the VaynerSports athletes.
I expect you in there
so that is number one.
Number two, I'm gonna go with...
Ooh, you know what?
Timbaland, the super producer
who's completely lighting up Instagram.
Timbaland the super producer,
I'm calling you out.
And finally... I got one.
The Undertaker, one of the
great wrestlers of all time.
Please join the challenge,
everybody go to allinchallenge.com.
Please support this, the
experiences are gonna be nuts.
We've been working,
bleeding out of the eyeballs
for the last week putting
this all together.
You're gonna be blown away what you're
about to see on social media.
#allinchallenge, please check it out
and please go to your
favorite celebrities,
athletes, and entertainers
and leave #allinchallenge
to get them involved.
The All-In Challenge, please, take it.